[Music]
[Applause]
here's one i don't know why this didn't
sell it's
asian versions of famous
people that is kevin spacey right there
i don't know why
this book didn't
it's actually quite astounding
is he listening to a car key i don't
know
don't examine too much all right it's
the picture we found all right all right
and there's more on the back right there
you've got dr oz oh that's good and
beyonce
this is a fantastic book that is that's
nice yeah i can't i can't imagine why
nobody would want that no well we've got
it now here's one that just didn't sell
i don't know why
the slug kama sutra right here
sexual positions
erotic sexual positions yes involving
slugs and then uh really they go into
more detail on the back you've got
everything there
you've got yeah back patio
highway to heaven i love it
there's one brooklyn bridge
and then there's flesh mob right do you
need a lot of slugs
although it is disappointingly thin yeah
[Laughter]
here's one ladies and gentlemen
things that never should have been sky
written things that never
should have been
wow
sky write that i don't know yeah and
then there's another example here in the
back well who would go to the trouble
to skywrite this and from a balloon that
would be hot hours no less it must be
sir mix-a-lot yeah exactly love the
reference anyway uh here's one and you
don't see lowercase very often
you know
in skywriting you know
you never see it you never see lowercase
you don't
just love seeing your knees and
everything i'm just enjoying it
here's one called
wise waldo waldo contemplates his own
existence
this is waldo yeah
just wondering about the meaning of it
all
here's another one of him on the back
he's just sitting there on the dock
thinking about it all
what does it all mean it's a very
melancholy contemplative waldo finally
getting a little solid there he is just
looking up at the stars
thinking about it all why is waldo i
don't know why he didn't sell and then
if i had one book that's my favorite of
all the books that i got it's this one
right here
guys who nailed your mom before your dad
came along
all right
i don't have any problem at all with
that guy the winner
that guy creeps me out and then there's
more on the back and this is just really
going to work
yeah
oh mom
[Laughter]
really mom a weather man